Heroes it's an oldfashioned Den
notion but the world can still use
them ready whatever it takes whatever it
takes we destroyed
Thanos but it's not over my work is
inevitable it will always be
more to finish
it
this is just the
beginning she tore a hole in
space there's a different
reality leading into
[Music]
ours what are you prepared to do I'm REM
fa your powers only make me stronger see
it can't be
matched can't be
controlled I'm
asking for one last
[Music]
fight
Monica
you cannot protect your
people but you can stand all without
standing
alone they're
[Music]
here the Marvels R
PG13 uh-oh Monica you got to fly no no
no black girl
magic if Peters Frid a get tickets now
now